(Banjo plays)
(Banjo and guitar play)
(Sings) Is this what it's like
to be alive?
I reached the point of no return
and I don't know if I've been burned
from the burned bridges in my life,
thinkin' you were wrong
and I was right.
Maybe I messed up,
either way it's too late for us.
'Cause baby I'm old with regret,
wishin' I could hold you and just forget.
Since I can't I'll just be
home but homesick,
wishin' you were mine
and I didn't hurt you like I did.
Can't go back to when we had a chance,
wishin' I could have a shot
at real romance.
Now I realize all the things
I could have had were in your cold hands.
I'm a fool for a dead romance.
Gone, gone, gone.
Is this what it's like to fantasize
about a love that never was alive
outside my mind or distance?
With time I clearly lost my sight,
thinkin' I was wrong
to ever leave your side.
But time's the harshest judge,
makes us think we were in love.
And now
I'm old with regret,
wishin' I could hold you and just forget.
Since I can't I'll just be
home but homesick,
wishin' you were mine
and I didn't hurt you like I did.
Can't go back to when we had a chance,
wishin' I could have a shot
at real romance.
Now I realize all the things
I could have had were in your cold hands.
I'm a fool for a dead romance.
Gone, gone, gone.
(Banjo and guitar play)
And baby I'm old with regret,
wishin' I could hold you and just forget.
Since I can't I'll just be
home but homesick,
wishin' you were mine
and I didn't hurt you like I did.
Can't go back to when we had a chance,
wishin' I could have a shot
at real romance.
Now I realize all the things
I could have had were in your cold hands.
I'm a fool for a dead romance.
Gone, gone, gone.
Is this what it's like?